good afternoon my name is Claude Steele
and I'm the Provost of Columbia
University and it's my role and my great
pleasure to welcome you to yet another
world leaders forum this this week
this event is co-sponsored with the
Columbia's committee for global thought
today we will be hearing an address from
Prime Minister malaise is an ally of
Ethiopia the Prime Minister's address is
titled the current global environment
and its impact in Africa Columbia
University President Lee Bollinger
launched the world leaders forum in 2003
as a university-wide initiative to
support uninhibited dialogue on the most
pressing economic political
environmental and social questions of
our time questions that with each
passing year have a larger and larger
global dimensions to them over the past
seven years the forum has offered an
opportunity for more than 15,000
students faculty and staff to directly
engage important figures from 48 nations
of the world representing all corners of
the globe our experience has confirmed
the animating principle of the world
leaders forum that only through informed
dialogue critical scholarship and a free
exchange of ideas will answer's emerge
to the biggest problems facing the world
today the role of universities in
creating a space for uninhibited and
critical dimension discussions of
controversial issues has been noted on
many occasions if anything the changes
we are seeing in public discourse serve
to heighten the importance of this role
universities not only are places where
difficult conversations are respected
and encouraged today it is sometimes
appears that universities may be the
only remaining venue where such
conversations occur with any regularity
we now are halfway through a week of
world leaders forum events held at
Columbia which coincide with the Fall
Meeting of the United Nations General
Assembly already a broad and diverse
group of
from Africa Europe and Asia have visited
our campus challenged us with their
views and enriched our understandings of
the world before this week concludes we
will also hear from the heads of state
of Portugal Croatia and Turkey every
visiting leader faces unscreened
uninhibited questions from our
university community at the conclusion
of his or her remarks the world leaders
forum offers an invaluable opportunity
to our students and faculty an
opportunity that would be difficult if
not impossible to replicate in any other
city or at any other University we are
grateful that heads of state and other
world leaders continue to express a
strong interest in coming here to speak
the recognition of colombia's world
leaders forum by heads of state around
the world signals that the value of the
forum extends well beyond the university
community assembled in the audience for
these addresses very often in the open
question-and-answer period that follows
an address foreign leaders are
confronted with probing questions that
they may not face in their home
countries providing such a forum for
debate and controversial ideas and
issues is central to the university's
free speech values its educational
values and its role as a global center
of learning today's questions and answer
session will be moderated by Mamadou
Diehl a professor of history and
director of the Institute for African
Studies at Columbia School of
International and public affairs for all
of these reasons it should be evident
that providing a university forum does
not imply an endorsement of the views
expressed in these addresses or the
policies pursued by these governments
but instead serves as a very different
purpose central to the University very
simply we have a responsibility to offer
our community the chance to engage in
conversations with men and women
directly involved in the major
challenges of the 21st century I would
like now to introduce University
Professor Joseph Stiglitz who is chair
of Columbia's Committee on global
thought who will
then introduce premier Prime Minister is
an owwie
professor Stiglitz no doubt is well
known to many of you he is one of our
proud Nobel laureates and he is a widely
recognized commentator on global
economic issues in an esteemed member of
the Columbia University faculty so with
no further ado I will turn this over to
Joe stinkles thank you very much
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to introduce Prime
Minister Meles Zenawi to Columbia
University to discuss the current global
environment and its impact on Africa let
me just say a few words about Prime
Minister Sinagua who is here in New York
this week with a hundred and 40 heads of
state attending the United Nations
General Assembly which is focused on the
Millennium Development Goals so we
appreciate his top taking the time to
visit our campus and talk about the
economic issues facing Africa in the
world economies current fragile state I
hope he will I'm sure he will say a few
words about Ethiopia's economic progress
as was mentioned following today's talk
there'll be a question and answer period
moderated by Mamadou deal director of
the Institute for African Studies and a
member of the Committee on global
thought let me say now a few words about
Otto MELAS Sonali he interrupted his
studies at the Medical Faculty of Addis
Ababa University in 1974 to join the
fight to overthrow the magista regime
which in turn had overthrown Emperor
Haile Selassie in the aftermath of one
of the worst famines of the world has
seen the famine of 1972 74 which had
killed an estimated 40,000 to 80,000
Ethiopians with some estimates be even
higher after 17 years of fighting in the
aftermath of the fall of the Soviet
Union they finally succeeded in ending
would have come to be called the Red
Terror which had earned the reputation
as one of the most oppressive regimes in
the world and MELAS at that point became
president of the transitional government
he was then elected prime minister in
1995 while fighting in the guerrilla war
he realized that the future of his
country would depend on economic
development and growth and that would
require an understanding of economics at
least I hope that was important and
there are some countries in East Asia
who think that engineers are better and
that economists would be better to send
away but anyway I think
comics is important he undertook his
studies through correspondence courses
eventually receiving degrees from the
Open University in the United Kingdom
and harass most University in
Netherlands Ethiopia has been noted for
its economic performance in fact my
encounter with EFT Opia began my first
visit as chief economist the World Bank
in 1997 and it was also my last visit as
chief economist of the World Bank in
2000 according to World Bank figures the
country had has shown a strong growth
for much of the last decade and
especially in the last few years from
2004 to 2008 it had a double-digit real
growth rate placing it among the very
top of the world that rate dropped not
surprising with a global recession but
different estimates still place at
around 70% and is projected to rise
again the Prime Minister has become an
active voice for Africa including
serving as chairman of the organisation
of the African Union and is currently
serving as co-chairman of the global
Coalition for Africa in 2004 he was
appointed by UK Prime Minister Tony
Blair as one of the commissioners taking
part in the Commission for Africa and he
played a critical role in shaping the
report of that Commission which in turn
has had a great deal of influence on
policies towards Africa beginning with
the Gleneagles key conference the Prime
Minister has also represented the
African continent a number of g8 and g20
meeting subsequently but recently he has
become greatly involved in the issue of
climate change which is having an
enormous impact on Africa probably the
region which has been most impacted by
climate change he has become the African
Union spokesperson on climate change and
he was asked by the secretary-general to
serve as the co chairman with UK Prime
Minister Gordon Brown of the panel
established after Copenhagen to follow
up on the financing pledges made at
Copenhagen to assist the developing
countries deal with climate change today
the world leaders forum and the
Committee on global thought
thank you for participating in this
academic dialogue with the Prime
Minister of Ethiopia and I look forward
to your remarks thank you thank you Joe
for that wonderful introduction the last
three decades which could be described
as the decades of the emergence and
triumph of new neoliberalism in key
centres of global power and hence
throughout much of the world have been
very bad decades for Africa they have
for all intents and purposes being lost
decades at the beginning of this period
Africa faced a huge debt burden and
associated macroeconomic imbalances and
low rates of economic growth due to weak
management of the economy and
unfavorable external circumstances it
was therefore forced to seek support
from the international financial
institutions which had by then become
key enforcers of the emerging neoliberal
paradigm Africa was was asked to undergo
fundamental neoliberal economic reforms
in return for the support it sought from
the international financial institutions
these reforms were sold as the ultimate
salvation for its problems and were
supposed to lead to sustained economic
growth and transformation the reforms
could not and did not lead to salvation
on the contrary the limited
industrialization of the continent that
had taken place since independence was
reversed with no economic revival inside
the emergence of neoliberalism at the
end of the 70s thus generated a lost
decade for Africa in the 80s the end of
the Cold War at the beginning of the 90s
heralded the triumph of neoliberalism
throughout the world indeed the 90s
was the decade not only of the time of
the paradigm but also of triumphalism of
neoliberal exemplified by such theories
at the end of history the new liberal
political and economic order was defined
as the ultimate destination of history
towards which all societies will and
must march the decade-long failure of
neoliberalism in Africa could not just
be blamed on the paradigm Africans had
to and were blamed for the failure of
the paradigm as they were alleged to
have been less than enthusiastic in
implementing it they were told that
their only option was to persevere and
carry out even more thoroughgoing
neoliberal reforms they could see for
themselves that neoliberalism was the
only game in town and they were reminded
of that very fact every time they
grumbled this insanity of implementing
the same failed neoliberal policies and
expecting different outcomes resulted in
another lost decade during the 90s while
Africa was mired in perpetual economic
crisis and associated political malaise
punctuated by horrific and senseless
violence neoliberal globalization was
making tremendous progress with
constantly changing centers of global
growth in the 80s it was Germany and
Japan who seemed to be unstoppable
and were leading the pack China was its
enormous human resources was also
entering a period of extraordinary
growth and transformation and
integrating with the global economy in
the 90s the former communist bloc in
East Asia in eastern Central Europe
collapsed and was progressively opened
up for business China became a rising
star of the global economy while India
was doing in the 90s what China had done
in the 80s while India and China was
emerging as new centers of global
economic growth Japan and Germany
steam and we're mired in prolonged
economic malaise the u.s. in the UK at
the heartland of new liberalism came
roaring back and were growing faster
than the rest of the developed countries
it was towards the end of the Roaring
nineties as Joe describes them that the
pretense of neoliberal reforms finally
leading to sustained growth in
transformation in Africa was finally and
more or less explicitly abandoned Africa
was now more or less explicitly being
managed as a lost case as a continental
ghetto on the margins of a fast
globalizing world the demand for the
commodities it produced and which
constituted the basis of its tenuous
linkage with a global economy was
limited and diminishing poverty in
Africa was seen to be endemic the new
name of the game does became not the
transformation of Africa's poverty
through neoliberal reforms through
neoliberal or other reforms but the
management of its chronic poverty the
objective became to alleviate poverty in
Africa and limit the damage of its
poverty to itself and to the rest of the
world a new generation of externally
driven poverty alleviation strategies
does mushroomed overnight throughout the
continent elevating the poverty and its
consequences of the Continental ghetto
was the objective of the global aid
business people seem to have more or
less given up on the productive
incorporation of Africa to the global
economy and appear to have spawned a
whole industry to manage the
consequences of its marginalization the
first decade of the 21st century
represents a period of post continuity
and change in Africa for a third decade
in a row the failed neoliberal orthodoxy
continued to be imposed on the continent
with broadly similar results at the same
time
the emergence of new players in the
global economy in general and the
emergence of China in particular was
beginning to have significant impact on
Africa's economic prospect the
commodities that Africa produces were in
far greater demand and were fetching the
highest prices in many degrees as a
result of the emergence of these new
players this development was the main
cause of the significantly higher growth
rate in Africa at the beginning of the
century investments in infrastructure
with her which had more or less which
had been more or less totally abandoned
together with the neoliberal reforms and
Africa's marginalization from the global
economy were initiated again by the new
global actors seeking Africa's
commodities the Continental ghetto was
beginning to strengthen its con its
economic linkage with the rest of the
world and the new centers of global
growth in particular as the emerging
powers were either opposed to
neoliberalism or reluctant to evangelize
on its behalf a new and different game
came to town the neoliberal game was
still the dominant game in town but it
was no longer the only one by the end of
the decade the biggest and the most
profound crisis of neoliberalism had
gripped the world neoliberalism which
had generated three decades long crisis
in Africa which had resulted in various
crises in Asia and Latin America in the
90s now had come back home to roost the
US and the UK were in the grip of the
deepest crisis since the Great
Depression of the 30s given the role
that the US economy plays in the world
the crisis is beginning to shake the
fundamental structures of neoliberal
globalization I am convinced that there
is a silver lining for Africa because of
the nature of the current global crisis
I say so for two fundamental reasons
first while the former Prime Minister of
the United Kingdom may have been a
little too optimistic when he pronounced
the Washington Consensus dead here in
New York it is nevertheless true that it
has been profoundly weakened and shaken
particularly outside its heartland the
crisis has shown that neoliberalism has
failed
not only in the peripheries as used to
be the case but also in its heartland
the crisis has also shown that those who
have rejected it have continued to
prosper even during the crisis the
crisis has also speeded up the changing
global economic power and further
weakened the dominant position
neoliberalism has had for decades
Africans have for the first time in
three decades real or alternatives to
the orthodoxy they now have a choice
that they have not had for a long time
the fact that Africans now have a choice
is in and of itself
fundamentally liberating above and
beyond that Africans now have a real
chance to chart a new course of
development one that incorporates
incorporates best practice elsewhere and
is capable of generating fast growth and
transformation Africans can of course
miss this new opportunity to make a
choice and make the wrong choice but
that would be their choice and their
mistake to make unlike the neoliberal
orthodoxy that was imposed on them from
outside the choices they make now are
theirs and theirs alone just as Africans
are capable of making the wrong choice
and missing the boat they are also
capable of making the right choice and
capitalizing on the new opportunity
created by the global crisis of
neoliberal
second the crisis has shown that Africa
is an essential part of the solution to
the current global economic problem the
US and UK can no longer borrow and spend
to keep the global economy moving while
the emerging powers can be a lot to fill
in the gap
they cannot fully compensate for the
lack of effective demand globally Africa
was its billion people has to be
incorporated in the global network of
production and consumption
if globalization is to have a new lease
of life the labor intensive
manufacturing that China is no longer
competitive in has to relocate somewhere
Africa is the main hinterland that is
available for global investment in labor
intensive manufacturing in the
production of tropical agricultural
products it is also a major supplier of
the mineral wealth that is required to
keep the global economy growing the
world cannot afford continental Ghetto
anymore while the need to incorporate
Africa in the global network of
production and consumption creates a new
opportunity for Africa it does not by
any means guarantee success the rest of
the world may lack the foresight and
leadership to effectively deal with the
current prolonged economic crisis by
among other things bringing a billion
people in Africa to the global network
we Africans may fail to capitalize on
the new opportunity that the girl the
current global conjecture has created
for us but the fact remains that we now
have an opportunity that we have not had
for decades the challenge for African
leaders posed by the current global
environment is thus unique and pregnant
with possibilities the challenge is to
use the demise of new liberalism as the
only game in town to change course and
chart a path of inclusive growth
formation the challenge is to use the
unique global environment to
productively link Africa with the rest
of the world and to forge a new and more
inclusive globalization while there is
no guarantee that the current crop of
African leaders will rise to the
occasion
it is not preordained that they will
fail the fact that it is now up to us as
Africans to choose to make our own
mistakes and learn from them is however
of historic importance fifty years after
the independence of Africa the current
crisis may yet engender
the second liberation of Africa I think
[Applause]
first of all let me thank the Prime
Minister for a very rich and powerful
presentation again my name is Mamadou
Jeff and hazard director of the
Institute for African Studies I was
asked to moderate this part of our event
today which is what Q&A so the rule of a
game are quite simple you have to mic in
behind when you want to ask a question
please move closer to the mics and I
will identify you and give you a floor
the organisation is quite simple you
have 20 minutes of question and we would
like to entertain many questions please
keep your questions short precise and
you will have a chance to ask your
question and I'm sure the Prime Minister
will be happy to answer them
so I will begin on my mr. prime minister
well thank you for your speech my name
is Patek math Demian our undergraduate
student here at Columbia I would like to
know where could you tell us how was
your how are your party and its allies
able to get ninety nine point six
percent of the vote in last major
election thank you
[Applause]
Prime Minister my party did not get
99.6% of the water got 99.6% of the sea
and there's a difference in
parliamentary systems in parliamentary
systems as you might know for example
the Labour Party in the United Kingdom
was in power with roughly 69 percent of
the vote it's a first pass deported
system you do not have to have the total
vote in a seat to win that seat if you
get 50% class one in every of the seats
you get a hundred percent of the seats
just even with just 50 plus one person
of the boat but we did get an
overwhelming majority of the vote and I
suspect after seven years of
double-digit growth 7 years of roughly
eleven point six percent growth after
seven years of very equitable growth
Ethiopia's Gini coefficient is zero
point two nine it is a lowest in the
continent and one of the lowest in the
world which means our growth has been
very broadly equitable given these two
facts alone I would be very surprised if
we didn't get overwhelming support
okay Thank You mr. prime minister my
question is regarding the Middle East
and I want to know your views on Iran
its nuclear program relationship with
the United States role in the region in
general
as you know we Africans have declared
Africa a nuclear-free zone and we would
like to make sure that there are more
nuclear free zones especially close to
our neighborhood I am not sure whether
Iran's nuclear program is for military
purposes or for civilian purposes there
are two sides to that story but I'm
pretty sure that nuclear a nuclear arms
race in the Middle East will be
catastrophic to the Middle East and it
would be very damaging to Africa and so
we support dialogue to resolve this
problem we support denuclearization in
the region and we believe that another
war in that part of the world could be
very damaging to everybody
last week we had the prime minister of
Bhutan come and his main point was a
gross domestic happiness I'm interested
to know what you think the most
important factor in the ethiopian
people's happiness is and what your role
in that factor is
well I want to study that concept of
gross domestic happiness it sounds very
interesting new idea but as of now I
can't say I have read enough to
understand it well and so my view may be
some extent out-of-date in the case of
Ethiopia my feeling is that the main
challenge the main challenge in Ethiopia
is poverty I'm sure many of you will
have heard of those of you who have a
trophy few people will have heard of it
in the context of poverty famine and war
and this have been killing people by the
millions so my hunch is that overcoming
poverty and ensuring food security could
contribute to the happiness of
Ethiopians and and therefore my main
focus at this stage is to achieve that
[Applause]
mr. prime minister you talked a lot
about choice free choice for Africans
and I assume for Europeans so my
question is should we really take you at
your word when you talk about free
choice when your country is known to
restrict the press and even restrict
websites that each opens my treaty
[Applause]
I think choice is very important is
fundamental to every human beings free
expression of himself or herself I
believe I have contributed my fair share
to fighting systems in Ethiopia that
were unmistakably unmistakably
oppressive I fought for 17 years to
remove the Mangusta dictatorship after
that we made sure that those previous
igniters were not accused of crimes were
given the opportunity that they denied
every other
which is that they were given the free
choice to express themselves including
through the media now when they do
express themselves through the media
those remnants of the Hmong story here
you would expect them to be less than
grateful to those who remove them from
power and so over the years in bringing
choice these Europeans we have had to
trample on a few toes and those those
have had difficulty accepting the status
quo in Ethiopia the status quo Ethiopia
is not one of repression of the press
status quo in Ethiopia is not or that of
repression of free choice is one of
building these opportunities my name is
my name is viola I'm an econ senior I'm
Nigerian so naturally I'm interested in
what goes on you need to appear the
influence on the continent is pretty
great my question is how different is
your regime from enjutsu since we know
in 1993 there was like an immense
repression of a student demonstration
and the same thing happened in 2005 and
this were the same things men get so did
that made people so annoyed at them how
different is your regime
[Applause]
well for those on the receiving end of
the Mangusta regime they would not have
any difficulty distinguishing our regime
from that of the master regime the
period of red I'm sure you will have
been told is a period when people were
killed without any recourse to the
courts and their families were charged
by the number of bullets that were used
to kill these people
that type of criminality and operation
is dead it's finished and it is not
coming back I understand some people
might have feelings about it but it is
not coming back
[Applause]
Thank You mr. prime minister my name is
Tim Kirk I'm from the public health
school a question of clarification or
definition the the major concept in your
talk it's surrounded neoliberalism which
played the role of the villain in your
talk and as we go from different place
different place people have different
definitions of neoliberalism so I wonder
if you could help us understand maybe a
thumbnail sketch of what you're talking
about when you talk about neoliberalism
and what element or set of elements in
there was the most harmful to Africa
neoliberalism as it applied to Africa
started from diagnosis of the African
economic problem in the 70s the
diagnosis was based on the assumption
that the problem in Africa was the
African state that the African state was
doubling in economic issues that were
should not be of its concern and that is
the reason why Africa was not making
progress so the solution to that problem
was to keep the African state small weak
and out of economic interference and so
the creation of so called Nightwatchman
state in Africa in an environment where
don't have it massive economic massive
market failures whether its
infrastructure or education or health
meant that all the necessary investments
that are required to kick the process of
development and industrialization
forward we're not forthcoming I'll give
you an example in infrastructure power
or telecommunication and so on the idea
was that the private sector would invest
in infrastructure in Africa
it didn't for 30 years it's only now
that the Chinese are invested so the
period of massive investments in
infrastructure in Africa where periods
were foreigners wanted Africa's
commodities first period being in the
19th century where Europeans needed
Africa's commodities and they got in
through colonialism then they carried
out massive investment in infrastructure
second period is the beginning of the
21st century where countries such as
India and China also needed these
commodities could not restore
colonialism did not want perhaps to go
to culinary so and so they invested in
infrastructure in a very different
manner so it's only at the beginning of
the 21st century with the emergence of
new powers that we have investment in
infrastructure and without that that
cannot be across so the bottom line is
the idea of me liberalism that we oppose
is that it does not allow the state to
play positive and active role in
addressing market failures that impede
development in Africa okay I would like
to take the privilege of moderator and
for the sake of gender balance to ask to
women in the side to ask for two next
questions I'm sorry
okay come up and ask you a question - I
would like to question no not you no not
you you wait for the two women and you
will ask your question
it's the number saying I love my of the
sky yeah is it about an out yeah my name
is Tessa Nomura say I am an alumni of
this Columbia School of International
public affairs my questions relating to
the Ethiopian economy has grown by more
than 10 percent yet recently the
Ethiopian bird has been devalued
significantly does this develop this
devaluation is meant to promote import
substitution does this mean that your
model of agricultural LED economy spot
or something's wrong with it
you're right we have had a steep
devaluation of our currency in recent
weeks there are a number of reasons for
it the first and most important reason
is that we have had again double-digit
inflation rates for more than two years
now and that clearly has demanded the
house
that needs to be corrected so we
devalued to correct the overvaluation of
our currency that came about as a result
of the high inflation we have had for
more than two years we needed to correct
them and we need to correct that in a
step-by-step manner we couldn't do much
when we were in high in a period of high
inflation because the devaluation might
have triggered even higher inflation so
we have to delay the devaluation and
exact time as we could safely do it and
we felt it's time now for us to safely
develop our currency to correct our
valuation that article is a few years
before the this is the main reason the
second reason is to promote exports and
as you might know our industrial and
economic development started as a whole
is one of export led development whether
it's in agriculture or in
and secondly while supporting exports we
also hope that the devaluation will push
import substitution forward we I would
argue that this is consistent with our
strategy but I can understand why people
would think that this may be midterm
correction on our own alpha but my
argument would be that it would be
consistent with our Stern
[Applause]
okay thank you my name is Roberto cogito
and as a student of Columbia University
I can honestly say that one of the
reasons that I chose this university was
for forums like this that give us a
forum for open and academic discussion
and I mean with that being said just to
further my friends point earlier that
was asked as far as media access in
Ethiopia what can you say our possible
justifications for let's say for example
VOA being denied access in Ethiopia or
or other media outlets now in addition
aside from that what can you say that is
actively being done from the Prime
Minister's perspective that can improve
relations with our neighboring countries
with you with Eritrea with Somalia with
Sudan what is actively being done today
that and I don't even just it's being
said that's done but it's actively being
done to ensure that this year five years
down the line ten years down the line
there won't be any tension now I do not
know if you know this but VOA is not
allowed to broadcast to the United
States by law
he's allowed to broadcast other
countries but not to the United States
because it is supposed to reflect the
policy of government in power of the day
now
VOA amharic service happened to be
dominated by people who are associated
with the previous regime and those who
are associated with the previous regime
tend to have a particularly jaundiced
view of events in ethiopia for
understandable reasons and we took a
page from the policy of the united
states and said the oil is not welcome
to podcast Ethiopia but that is
different from the right of expression
by citizens freedom to express oneself
is a fundamental right of every citizen
and that right as you might know
properly protected in Ethiopia now with
regard to relations with our neighbors
we have excellent relations with all of
our neighbors with the exception of
Eritrea we have excellent relations with
Sudan we actually happen to be one of
very few governments in the world who
can talk in confidence with both the
government in the north and the SPLM in
the south we have excellent relations
with booty
we have excellent relations with Kenya
we have excellent relations with the
Somali government we have very bad
relations with a group called al-shabaab
but it's understandable that we would
have very bad relations with al-shabaab
because it's a terrorist group linked
with al-qaeda in the only country
backing al-shabaab in the region is
Eritrea and as you know the Security
Council imposed sanctions on area for
that reason because it was supporting
this the Security Council and the
African Union first that Erica needed to
be penalized and so it has been
penalized understandably therefore those
of us who are not particularly happy
with the al-qaida types have had
difficulty relating positively towards
the current regime
Eritrea but I want to also remind you
that our government was the first
government in the world to recognize the
independence of Eritrea from if you
after the referendum and again this is
the reason why some of Europeans have a
particularly doing this view of our
government okay I'm very sorry but we
have room left only for no more than
four questions so I will take two
questions from this side and two from
this in anticipation of your comfort if
you're coming here to Colombia some of
the media covering your arrival here use
the word dictator in their articles do
you have any regrets from your long
tenure as leader of your country I have
none am particularly proud with the
results with the with my track record
I'm particularly proud of the results of
the efforts of my party I believe I have
made a modest contribution to the
success of my part in Ethiopia both in
removing a particularly brutal
dictatorship of the Mangusta regime and
in rebuilding Ethiopia on a new basis
after the removal of that dictatorship
so
[Applause]
Prime Minister it's true that you fought
part and you defeated the most brutal
regime in modern Ethiopian history the
dud that's very true and I think it's
safe to say that you claim that your
government is under a democracy but
there is proof that shows the contrary
for example just shuttering the
independent press in Ethiopia especially
after the 2005 election jamming
international broadcast stations
including it's your dad's independence
satellite television station um your
troops killing nearly nearly 200 unarmed
protesters who were protesting an
election that overseers were neutral
sent was very non transparent the
jailing of many people who do not share
ideas including the leader of the
largest opposition group but to climate
Enza and with these facts in life do you
see how people would not see that as a
democracy do you see that and if you
have a contrary belief with that in
light can you explain to us and how that
is a democracy
I can understand people who have had
inadequate chance to consider the facts
to see for themselves coming to the
conclusion that you appear to have come
to understand that I'm just saying that
something yeah please please let me take
one of your facts let him answer and
that is that of were talkin with AXA
this lady was taken to court an
independent court that was observed by
both representatives of the European
Union and the American imbecilities she
was sentenced to a long prison sentence
after serving few weeks she sought
pardon from the government she admitted
that she committed a crime she admitted
that she had been properly tried in a
proper court of law
and she sought pardon from the
government in the people of Ethiopia in
the interest of reconciliation and
progress in our country I felt that she
should be partnered and she among others
was part and released after she was
released she rebuilt her party continued
to rebuild a party for about 11 months
and she went abroad for a visit during
that visit abroad she issued a statement
to the effect that she did not ask for
pardon and that she was not given that
now our law partner law says that if a
pardon is given and sought under false
pretences or given under false pretences
it is automatically null and void
so if she didn't ask for pardon then the
pattern given to her was completely
indigent when she came back from abroad
the police told her that her statement
would necessarily lead to her being
detained again unless she were to admit
that she did indeed seek pardon and was
indeed given pardon then the pattern
given to her would be legally invalid
she was given a month to think about it
during this month many friends including
ambassadors in the time in addis talked
to her to try to convince her that
because her pardon her plea for pardon
was a basis of her freedom if she denied
it she would be forcing the hand of the
government and would have to be put put
back in prison she didn't feel convinced
that she should
retract the statement she issued in in
Sweden and so at that stage we had we
had no option but to detain given her
past practice I wouldn't be surprised if
she asked for pardon again and given the
practice of the government I wouldn't be
surprised if the government were to
pardon idea to pardon her again so I can
go on through all of the facts that you
had in the same manner but I am sure I
would be boring no no no no no let over
people ask how many terms may have Prime
Minister's serve in Ethiopia and I'd
like your thoughts on the concept of
term limits again I'm sorry I will take
the last question here I suppose you are
aware that in a parliamentary system the
party that wins the majority of the
seats
gets the power every time there are term
limits in the United States but none in
the United Kingdom I would hope you
understand that the United Kingdom is
perhaps just as Democratic as the United
States and that the parliamentary system
is just as Democratic as a presidential
system the presidential system requires
term limits first primer prime
ministerial systems or parliamentary
systems do not require presidential
systems but in case you are wondering
whether I have plans to stay in power
until until Kingdom Come I can assure
you that this will be my last term in
power last question genetic prime
minister MELAS I were to applaud you for
exercising a different type of economic
choice in 2004 I bought ticket Archie
Mingus tea my dear friend I planned for
you to take control of your own coffee
brands he brought it to you he had the
courage to come and you had the strength
to pursue that very very well and I have
to tell a little story that you were
reported to us and in just one moment
what we did together was to bring in
hundreds of millions of dollars for the
coffee farmers more than the World Bank
tells me they achieved in rural income
we changed the paradigm of Africa in
terms of intellectual property owned by
the people and we've convinced the US
government this was all a good thing
there's neither supporting coffee in the
first place but I have to ask you just
one thing and that is
ambassador Samuel s fr and I were
fighting in that battle against big
coffee and particularly Starbucks and he
said to me hit said he had been worried
one dark day when we might lose and he
said that he asked you if if the perhaps
Ethiopia should give him and you said
I'm not authorized to surrender these
rights these were the ownership of the
historical heritage coffee brands and he
said what do you mean
and I'm heard from him and I've repeated
in many forms including the g8 Committee
on intellectual property that you said
these are assets and future generations
and they didn't tell me I could give
them away
I approaches well for some people who
may not know this if you appear is the
source of Arabica coffee and so we can
rightly claim the intellectual property
right of Arabica coffee together with
some of our friends in the United States
we wanted to do that we wanted to
register some of our coffee varieties we
have over 200 we have over 200 coffee
varieties in Ethiopia and we wanted to
patent as it were two or three of them
as a starting point we made some
progress in the United States first but
some of the major coffee companies would
not were not happy with it
and so with the support of friends here
particularly Oxfam yes we tried out very
best in the end I think we have
succeeded in registering three of our
coffee varieties here and in Europe we
have ways to go in terms of registering
our coffee variety in Japan but we will
do it and obviously I do not have any
right to abandon that intellectual
property I'd created past it Europeans
created it over thousands of years and
it does not belong to me it belongs to
all if Europeans of the future so I had
no right to negotiate on this on this
right I I would have been happy to
negotiate had it with my property
or my life but it was one I'm very sorry
it was the last question we don't have
time for additional questions so I would
like to ask Prime Minister if he has
closing remark and reacting to the type
of engagement he experienced today with
our community I welcome the engagement
of students this afternoon the fact that
they care enough about Ethiopia to try
to find out what is happening in
Ethiopia even if what they found out was
not necessarily consistent with the
reality they did try and I appreciate
that very much
if your Pia is a poor country it's been
mired in conflict for decades it is in a
very rough rebel neighborhood
Somalia is just to the east of us and
Sudan is to the west of us we are in
between these two major fires so that's
a very tough neighborhood but I want to
tell you all that we are making progress
that we are getting out of the cycle of
poverty and violence and that this is
open for everybody to see so I'd like to
invite you all to come in visit artists
[Applause]
I would like to thank all of you for
participating to this debate and
promoting the global debate and I would
like also to thank the Prime Minister
for engaging in a very frank exchange
with the Columbia community thank you
very much
[Applause]